hi I'm Kelly from our studio and this
video is a demo of programmatic
deployment of a shiny application to our
studio konnekt using Jenkins and github
web hooks this deployment pipeline
leverages new our studio connect server
AP is for content management that have
just become available in our so you
connect 1.7 of 0 this is the deployment
pipeline that I've built using github
and Jenkins to move from the our studio
ide all the way to our studio konnekt so
here's the application that I'm
interested in programmatically jipang to
connect I'll show it to you here in the
our Studio IDE you can interact with it
here locally it'll also show it to you
as already deployed to my connect server
so here it is on the connect server you
can see here that it's just a basic
histogram shiny application and I've
changed the color of the histogram to
red now pull up my IDE again and say I'm
interested in changing the color from
red back to something more subtle like
blue so I'm going to do that I'm going
to use a git branching strategy I'm
checking out a new branch which I'm
calling new branch and now I'll be able
to commit all of my code changes to this
branch before pushing up to github so
here I'm just changing the color from
red to dark blue and then I'm going to
save that and test the app locally here
just locally I like the color so now
I'll push that change up to my github so
to do that I will add this change and
then write a little commit message here
about what happened to the code let's
say I changed the color
and then I'll push my branch up to
github
so now if I go over to my github
repository here you'll see I have a new
branch that I can then open a pull
request on so here I'm just opening a
pull request for this change so that I
can merge the branch into master and
push that change information over to
Jenkins I will pull request ready to go
and at this point I could request a
review from somebody else on my team
while I'm here I'll show you in the
settings that I have a web hook already
preset up to talk to Jenkins from my
github repo if you want to see more
information about how to set that up
check out the blog in the description
below but now I'm going to go ahead and
merge my PR into master and that will
kick off my Jenkins job this is my
Jenkins server I'm going to sign in
again real quick here you can see that I
have this free style of Jenkins project
that's deploying my code changes over to
our studio konnekt again for more
information on how to set up this free
sale project check out the blog in the
description below so I go over to
connect refresh and I can see I have a
blue histogram instead of a red one go
back and show you real quick some of the
things that you can explore in Jenkins
based on each build if you're interested
in looking at what happened you can
always go into your console output in
Jenkins and investigate each job you'll
see here that we had a success